I want to congratulate Andrew Yang for running
a good clean campaign, but yang has ended
his campaign.
Andrew Yang deciding to drop out of the presidential
race after receiving just 2.8% of the vote
in this week's New Hampshire democratic primary.
Andrew Yang said for many months, he's not
here just to run a good campaign.
He's here to be the nominee and to defeat
Donald Trump and to be president.
And we knew months ago that he did not have
a path to that nomination.
Many of his supporters, a good people I'm
sure, insisting via email and Twitter and
Reddit and YouTube and all of those platforms
insisting to me that yang will be the nominee.
Iowa will be a catalyst for growth, which
will propel him in New Hampshire, which will
propel him.
And you know, you got the idea, this is the
end of the road for Andrew Yang.
However, sending a series of tweets yesterday
saying, I am so proud of this campaign.
Thank you to everyone who got us here.
We'll be back and re tweeting his wife's tweet,
quoting him sort of like an inception sort
of thing from his concession speech where
he said, being your candidate has been the
privilege of my life.
This was the right move and I'm glad that
Andrew Yang has done the right thing mathematically.
He did not have a shot at this point in time.
He's clearing the space.
I am glad that Andrew Yang ran though.
He, uh, appeared on the program early.
Once he started getting more attention, he
started ignoring us.
Okay.
I don't hold it against him.
He still ran an issue based campaign.
We didn't have to agree about every policy.
We didn't have to agree about the implementation
of every single policy, but he ran on the
issues and he is gone.
Now in terms of other people that should drop
out.
Looking at the results from last night, you've
got Tom Stier who grabbed 3.6% of the vote
in New Hampshire.
But remember Tom Stire is actually polling
really well in South Carolina because he's
just been pouring money in and STI or likely
is going to get delegates in South Carolina,
so I think Syrah can justify staying in at
least until South Carolina to see what kind
of delegates he gets, see what happens then
and then decide if he has enough momentum
to keep going into super Tuesday or whether
it's time to get out.
He could pick up enough delegates in South
Carolina to maybe end up with some negotiating
power at the convention or to get some kind
of an exit endorsement deal from a different
candidate.
I don't know, but he at least has a path to
some delegates a tool.
See Gabardi yesterday got 3.3% of the vote
she should get out.
Remember, Stier is viable in South Carolina
based on polling tool.
C is not polling viable in any primary that
I was able to find.
Not only those tools do not have a path to
the nomination.
I don't see tools.
See having a path to a single delegate right
now.
I don't see any point in her staying in.
She at least tweeted yesterday, late last
night that she's continuing st quote.
My deepest thanks goes out to all of our incredible
supporters in New Hampshire and across the
country.
I am so grateful to you all about to lay my
head down here in Charleston, get a few hours
sleep and then continue sharing the message
of our campaign in South Carolina and beyond.
She should get out.
Then you have Deval Patrick who got 0.4% yesterday.
Nice guy, our former governor here in Massachusetts.
I've interviewed him a few times even though
every time he thinks my name is Mark, I don't
hold that against him, but he should get out
and Michael Bennett last night actually getting
out announcing that he is ending his campaign
for president.
So really, uh, yang and Bennet already got
out.
Stier is likely going to get some delegates
in South Carolina.
So I see him staying in.
Make sense.
Tool seat and Deval should get out right away.
Let me know what you think.
Tomorrow we're going to go through the math
that increasingly points to what contested
convention, and here's the really important
thing to understand.
If you are the democratic establishment and
your goal is not so much about, well we really
want Joe to be the nominee versus we really
want Amy to be the nominee.
If your goal is just, we don't want it to
be Bernie and probably we don't want it to
be Warren, you have an asymmetrical path to
victory.
It is very similar, and I use this analogy
last week, if you were in a football game
and you were up seven points, you don't need
to prevent the other team from scoring.
You just need to prevent a touchdown.
The other team needs a touchdown in order
to win.
So you have asymmetrical strategies.
The authentic needs to get over the goal line
and get a touchdown because they're down seven
the defense can actually play a defense where
you would even allow some gains and a field
goal potentially, but you've got to make damn
sure that there isn't a touchdown.
That is the asymmetrical situation right now
in terms of the Progressive's versus the establishment
in the democratic primary.
Uh, the, the, as the cap to my Sharpie flies
off, um, if you want to prevent Bernie from
being the nominee, you know that super delegates
get to vote on the second round at the convention.
You merely need to prevent Bernie from getting
enough delegates to secure the nomination.
So it doesn't really matter if the delegates
all go to Biden or Amy or if they split enough
delegates to prevent Bernie from winning on
the first ballot.
Your path is simply to keep this thing going
and keep people picking up enough delegates
that Bernie doesn't get them all.
Tomorrow we're going to look at the math.
We only have two primary so far, but so far,
if the same trend continues, if support does
not consolidate, um, we are rapidly heading
towards a convention in which, um, there,
there will likely be a second round of voting
required.
So that's on tomorrow's program.
We'll have continued coverage of yesterday's
and
you have the results on our Instagram page.
Make sure
you're following us there
at